news daily from science mission channel
clustering is important for effective
reliable excitation of the cells and
signal transduction researchers show
that dispersed calcium channels also
increases intracellular calcium does not
affect transcription of genes on the
other hand clustering of calcium
channels in the plasma membrane
microdomains not only exits the cells
but also regulates gene expression they
are by coupling excitation and
transcription for the sustained
signaling next chromosomal
rearrangements may result in gene fusion
leading to cancer authors in the journal
Cell reports identified a gene fusion
found in the Asians which when expressed
cost raw inhibition and dramatic loss of
epithelial cell phenotype with long
protrusions indicating of
epithelial-mesenchymal transition thus
gene fusion causes epithelia
disintegration possibly leading to
stomach ion leakage and might contribute
to invasiveness once a cell is
transformed for more news visitors at
www science mission calm or science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching